so I am director of film studies and
associate professor of English at a
place called Muhlenberg College which is
in Pennsylvania and I'm also on the
board of a group called the organization
for transformative works which is a
group that a bunch of media fans of
which I am one started to advocate for
and protect the history of fan culture
and I say fan culture which have
antedates remix culture which is what
I'm really talking about but fans have
been doing versions of what we now call
social media what we now call remix
culture for many years before digital
culture right fans did in analog form or
were one of the groups that did often in
analog form the kind of thing that's
really now becoming very commonplace in
the digital world and there were reasons
that fans came together to form an
advocacy group I mean I think this is
kind of where our links are I am coming
to from the you know humanities side of
the force from English and film studies
but I often now work with lawyers and
essentially the work that I do as a
scholar of remix and a scholar of the
kind of cultural production that people
have been doing you know not just since
2005 when YouTube was founded but before
YouTube right I mean the people whose
work I'm interested in celebrating
writing criticism about discussing the
utility there of our people who've been
doing remix works in the 1970s in the
1980s with VCRs with you know much more
primitive kind of computers with much
more with different kinds of tools and
so I'm often sort of the work that I do
as a humanities scholar is often working
in concert with lawyers from groups like
the Electronic Frontier Foundation or
Stanford fair use right to try to
advocate for the legitimacy and the
importance of this work in the new
digital market which I'm sure you know
or at least I think that you you know if
you're in this class the rules of the
internet are not the same as literally
the legal rules right so YouTube can do
takedowns on kind of what it wants as a
sort of private company which is sort of
different with what's actually fair use
but there's so there's a kind of
productive tension going on there as
people are sort of advocating and making
clear that these works deserve
protection we're going to kind of
commercial entities like YouTube or
other kinds of social networks or
the places on the internet to say this
kind of work needs to be you know
allowed to exist and needs to be kind of
embraced in a different way so I think
it's probably through our connection to
the advocating in favor of remix works
and participate every culture that we
intersect so my talk today I'm gonna
give you just a lot of information I'm
gonna just sort of throw all sorts of
things at you and then we can talk
afterwards in the QA about what parts of
it are interesting but I'm gonna kind of
take you on a sort of whirlwind tour
through remix culture with an emphasis
on sort of fan produced remixes partly
to talk about the kind of speech and the
kinds of arguments and the kinds of art
that fans have made and why those works
are important and so the first thing
that I want to talk about and again I
don't know how much work you've done and
this may be you know a refresher for you
or this may be more humanities-based
than you're used to in this course I
don't know but I want to survey the
definition of mass culture because remix
culture really happens in a kind of mass
culture environment in a different kind
of cultural environment that's not such
a binary between mass culture and the
remix it's just culture right for a long
time the kind of stuff that we just that
we're calling remix culture was just
what culture was right if you were doing
that all the millions of people who did
the sort of art Thorian tales right they
didn't say to themselves I'm remix nging
Arthur Tales when Hamlet when
Shakespeare wrote Hamlet which was the
eighth version of Hamlet he didn't say
I'm doing a remix of Hamlet right that
was just what art was you told and
retold stories you put your spin on them
you did different takes on them um but
it's really with the rise of mass
culture that you then have this idea of
remix culture right so it's a phenomenon
of mass culture and so I'd like Richard
Romans definition which we're going to
go through in pieces but I'll give it
you all at once to start right a
definition of mass culture mass culture
and societies like this one includes
voluntary experiences produced by a
relatively small number of specialists
for millions across the nation to share
in similar or identical form
simultaneously or nearly so with
dependable frequency mass culture shapes
habitual audiences around common needs
or interests and it's made for profit
right and so the next bit is like what
these are the pieces of that it's a long
definition and you might say like well
what do you mean by this voluntary
experiences meaning he
omens talking about kind of
entertainment and cultural experiences
he's not talking about things people
need to survive like food and clothes
and houses that you have to buy anyway a
Big Mac maybe a kind of branded sort of
food but you have to eat some food so
he's talking about math culture is on
some level of voluntary experience small
number of specialists the sense that and
you mean I hope you don't have this
sense I hope you're young enough that
this is actually not your default
anymore but the sort of sense that I
grew up with it like normal people don't
make movies specialists make movies
there's a little group of specialists in
LA right culture comes from them they
make movies and they give it to us right
that there's an elite group you don't
write novels right there are a couple of
professional novelists and they make
culture and then you if you're lucky get
to go to the store and just read it you
don't get to make TV you just show up
for TV right and somebody else makes it
in broadcast it to you you went out of
maker you are a consumer of that culture
right so the idea that in mass culture
only a couple of people make culture
right um and and sell it right and again
that's the next part for millions in
identical form right so that mass
culture is not like I knitted you a
sweater it's such as such as on Friday
night and everybody sees it right such
such as it's a TV show fringe fringe is
on Friday night right we all watch it at
the same time it's made by specialists
it comes to us identically right your
episode of Fringe is exactly the same as
my episode of Fringe where the sweater
that your grandmother made you is not
the same as the sweater sweater my
grandmother made me right you see
they're saying so there's a sense of of
the industrial kind of process there
that for millions of people they get it
in similar identical form Omen glosses
this is wrap yes Christmas know by which
he means you and I have exactly the same
in mmm song or jay-z song right it's
exam it's a mass-produced item your
Christmas holiday may not be my
Christmas holiday right that the kinds
of things that you and your family do
are individualized they're local they're
not mass culture at least not yet right
they may be getting to be mass culture
if you say I always watch the peanuts
special or I always do this but right
now right that sense that the culture
has actually sort of done identically
simultaneous they are nearly so right
the sense that everybody has every
he knows that the Emmys were on
everybody knows it was the MTV Music
Awards everybody saw Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows right everybody
knows that Beyonce got pregnant my
husband said does everybody know that
Beyonce is pregnant everybody knows
right this is a mass cultural event that
we all have to have at the same time
dependable frequency right TV runs
regularly a magazine write the June
issue the July issue movies rocky to
Rocky 3 rocky for a new harry potter
book every you know year and a half
right that for some sense of dependable
frequency to build a habitual audience
to buy right around demographics right
the group the watch the commercials on
any TV show it tells you about the
demographics it's aiming for men it's
aiming for women over a fiftieth aiming
for seniors right and for profit and so
this is the context right this is a sort
of gigantic large mass cultural context
in which remix culture of our
contemporary time is taking place so
what is remix culture right I have like
4 people's definitions of this I don't
know if you've read any of these guys
right Lawrence Lessig calls it readwrite
culture right that's not receive only
like the old television model right I
sit there and just get broadcast to but
the sense that I talk back I write back
I you know I I go to television well a
pity after I've seen my latest episode
and I write my review I go to a blog I
go to live Journal I read a story I make
a video I do a remix right so that sense
of readwrite if not read-only culture
Clay Shirky talks about the fact that he
has this line about a screen without a
mouse is broken right if he talks about
television as being a one-way broadcast
mechanism and now we have the Internet
where it's sort of understood that
something comes to you and you talk back
to it right you you have an input device
in your culture that is relatively new
right at least into mass culture mass
culture was not used to that sense of
talking back there's a guy called Pettit
who talks about the Gutenberg
paranthesis there's a complicated idea
I'm going to summarize in two seconds
but this is what I was talking about
about Shakespeare there's an argument
that culture used to be a lot more like
this before
Gutenberg and the rise of print print is
actually the first mass culture right
where you print a book and it's a
one-way device sent out and specialists
write books and you then are readers
that before that in a more oral culture
there was a moment where culture was
more local if you wanted to hear music
you played music
or you we're in your family where there
was music played or if you wanted to
hear story you somebody told you a story
right the sense of culture was if you
wanted you know you you you wrote a
horse for fun like you rode the horse
you didn't watch horses run on TV right
I mean some level track on television if
you're watching horses run on TV your
maths the sort of math cultural
experience is a race right that you're
not even in that you're watching you
become a kind of spectator to a horse
racing I find really depressingly that's
happened with poker right I mean I feel
like in my own youth you know poker if
you said you were gonna do poker tonight
it meant you were gonna play poker
now it may mean that you're gonna watch
poker on the poker Channel right so the
idea that pokers become a spectator
sport in which you're not supposed to
participate except by watching right is
is a the mass is making poker into mass
culture there's a young they're starting
a musical the major in a major league
baseball Major League like video gaming
there's a video game league where people
going pro playing video games is anybody
heard of this right so Major League
Gaming right I think that I think it's
an interesting moment where I still
think that like you play the game but
the idea that actually specialists right
if you remember omens definition
specialists might play the video game
better than you the way that specialists
are writing books and specialists are
making movies and music and singing
right and you might just become a
spectator to watching video games you
might watch other people make video
games right
anyway this this side of the idea that
our side is now trying to kind of break
down those distinctions is actually sort
of suggesting that that the Gutenberg
parenthesis is closing at this moment of
a mass culture that you could not talk
back to is the aberration and not the
norm right the the the sense of a more
organic culture where everybody
participated used to be that we have the
Gutenberg parenthesis and now we're
moving back to a place where everybody
is a participant in culture Henry
Jenkins talks about remix culture
happening as a response when culture is
owned by corporations like what happens
when the stories in your head that are
meaningful to you right are no longer
folklore or religious stories or stories
from your family but are stories that
somebody has like a trademark right that
in your heart is Luke Skywalker but it's
Luke Skywalker TM right like you
think about Luke Skywalker you can't
think about Harry Potter right even
though your brain is full of it right
and in some ways these are really
meaningful stories to you that that that
story is owned by somebody else and that
your ability to retell or reshape or
live or experience that story in a
meaningful way
somehow is somehow somebody else's
intellectual property right and so these
are definitions or the ways in which
people are beginning to talk about remix
culture again bringing huge numbers of
ideas at you but so hopefully some of
these are familiar I'm so many different
kinds of remix culture um so here's
Wonder Woman remixed art and I'm
something with sort of fan art has a
point of view
I'm as a scholar most interested in the
art that has a kind of counter narrative
or giving you a narrative that is in
some ways talking back to or resistant
to the mainstream narratives of popular
culture right so this is actual this is
a Wonder Woman right cover you can see
and then what I think is interesting
these are two pieces of fan art I almost
want to be tempted to do a little bit of
like guess the gender of the drawers but
uh of the artist um again I mean this is
a sort of piece of fan art that I think
is obviously taking right doing a read
of Wonder Woman in one direction I mean
if anything she's what I mean you don't
think she could be wearing less but she
can she is actually sort of wearing
lasted is slider and possibly less
capable of fighting people this is a
woman fan artist who I like a lot who
was Wendy's I love about this is she's
like what if one of them were actually
like a feisty Greek chick which is by
the way what she's supposed to be right
she's an Amazon she's from Greece people
from Greece never look Greek grad I mean
she started doing her in this way as
like what if she were a Greek princess
right and you really do I think get a
sense of Wonder Woman here as a Greek
princess but again this fan art is a
point of view it's not just I think
replicating you know the original but
there's a kind of take on what the myth
or the Methos
means right so again it has a point of
you and that's necessarily a
counter-narrative
fan art often constructs counter
narratives right not just in terms of
gender now this is my PS if it's hard to
be a comic book fan this is an actual
statue put out by Marvel very hard to be
a comic book fan and women comics fans
were a little like apeshit about it I
also love that she's believe it or not
doing his laundry would you can't see in
this view of the statue
but this mary-jane statuette she's she's
she's doing his laundry and there's
actually a down in the actual statuette
there is a laundry detergent bottle and
some female fans right and a lot of
times will do this will draw the male
characters the way that the female
characters are posed to try to indicate
like how demeaning they find it right so
this really is parodic speech right you
you you you can't imagine right the body
language that they're giving poor for
spider-man here um so right this this
fan art is really speaking back in this
way and caused such a huge stir in in
comic books community um but not just
gender in terms of race this is an
actual promo for show called
supernatural which is still running
which maybe some of you watch which is a
fun show it's a show about two brothers
who travel the country in a I think 72
Impala or something like that correct
Minnie all right in an old car with a
trunk full of guns and they fight demons
okay that's what they do their demon
fighting brothers who travel the u.s. in
their old cars and fight demons and so
people have done fans like and if they
were black that would be a very
different story alright um the whole
conceit of like the ways in which that
they would be traveling affects somebody
did a fantastic fan comic we're
literally in the first few minutes
they're draw the black Sam and Dean of
Supernatural are traveling the country
with their car full of weapons and like
they're pulled over and like in Arizona
and they're asked for their papers for
like immigration and they're like
deported and then like the whole town
dies because the demons get everybody
right so there was kind of a comment on
like who gets to roam the country
totally free I think they were pulled
over for driving while black right and
so this sort of sense that you know that
the culture may not work or that these
archetypes don't necessarily work in
ways for the entire audience right so
this is again a fan artist cultural
criticism also in terms of sexuality
right I think people have people think
about this most when they think about
kind of resistant and you know the
internet is for porn right and they
think about to the idea of sexually
explicit stuff or rule 42 right if
they're if it exists there is porn of it
right every was like yes right 34 34 42
is the magic right well that was also it
yes
34 right it exists this porn of it so if
it's Jenny and Tom
this is leave it or not Holmes and
Watson being quite naughty and
Victoria's is from Firefly right so if
it exists somebody's making porn of it
and I think that's what people think
about often when they think of fan art
and the Internet um I want to kind of
make a not that I hope I don't need to
defend it to you but if I do I want to
make a particular argument about it that
not only does fan out on the internet
tend to deal with queer sexualities and
alternative sexualities but I think that
there is something kind of important
about iterating the importance of
sexuality period and I think in the case
of doing erotic art that is tied in with
characters that we know already that in
some ways it's almost anti-pornography
if pornography kind of objective I mean
if one of the arguments against
pornography is that it objectifies
people um in a weird way to imagine
beloved characters and erotic situations
is actually kind of completing the
dimensions of their lives it's actually
not about seeing them as objects it's
actually kind of adding sexuality as I
kind of compliment to other parts of
their character and so I have this quote
here from a fan named Shoshanna who who
said this where she sort of said that
like fan art in general and and
particularly she was talking about slash
art which is named for the the
punctuation mark literally this slash
mark between that the the names of
people that you're linking erotically
right whether if it's Kirk Spock or
Hermione Tonks or whoever you were
linking she said it was the first
literature she ever saw that integrated
people's sex lives with their lives
outside of bed right and MOSI honor is a
fiction people have sex but the
narrative doesn't show how they carry
themselves how they interact with their
partners on the other side you have porn
in which the characters have no regular
lives they just have sex right so one of
the that I love about the way in which
she is figure this which is to say that
in this kind of work like everyday life
or work life is not separate from sex
life is that actually she's kind of
making an argument that the mainstream
culture is kind of pathological from the
way in which it sort of walls off sexual
things from all the rest of your life do
you see I'm saying right that there's
there's the rest of your life and which
somehow sex is completely not
appropriate and then there's this whole
other literature of porn or stories of
porn where that where sex is appropriate
but the sense in which those things are
not allowed to kind of exist and and who
who that structure advantages or
disadvantages
I think this desire to kind of bring you
know to
to sort of tell stories or like Buffy
goes out and fights vampires and then
comes home and has sex and then gets up
and has breakfast right then cleans her
teeth um
fanfiction in fact often does deal with
the bits that don't get shown right I
mean whether it's people drawing like
literally where the bathrooms are on the
enterprise or or also in fact I forgot
if I edited in did I I did children and
and pregnancy right their whole
particular for women right I think this
is the kind of thing that people laugh
at very quickly where they're like oh my
god there's nothing called em preg right
which is male male pregnancy stories and
you're like seriously people are on the
internet writing Batman is pregnant with
Superman's love child and the answer is
yes people are from my point of view I
think it's really interesting that like
there are no nobody on TV is ever
pregnant ever has children their
children not integrated everybody knows
that kind of cliche of the if they are
pregnant like the kid grows up in two
episodes right this is sort of that
often they often if it's science fiction
there's some sort of magical drug right
and then they're 18 like in ten minutes
right because like nobody knows what to
do with with these other parts of life
right um for me this is a political
argument there is something feminist to
me about integrating sex life
integrating children here oh this is the
Sherlock BBC in Watson with their brood
of small children here's right Harry and
Draco experiencing spontaneous male
pregnancy right and you might say well I
don't get it like and the answer is you
know what thinking and worrying about
pregnancy is actually a really
significant thing for a large number of
people half the people on the planet
right are often sort of thinking about
these things right and yet this is an
experience it's totally not represented
in in mainstream culture and so I think
that it's not surprising that a
literature dealing with pregnancy and
children would have sprung up and again
these are certainly not the kinds of
stories that would be sort of authorized
or or you know but by by the manger the
makers of these works um so this was
this was visual art music I don't know
if you've done any have you done any
mashups or music and class yet a little
bit um I thought I would play did you
know this Marshall got snookered you
know this piece this is let me see if
this will play so these are classic
mashups of one thing against another
right juxtaposed to make meaning I've
picked you that I think are
not just good I think I think we all I
think we're in a mash up culture now
that we might just be like that sounds
awesome right like that might be the
sole reason for it to exist is like that
sounds great um the examples that I'm
picking are ones that I think not only
sound great but are also interesting
have kind of intellectual arguments or
say something beyond just sounding cool
so Marshall got snookered let's people
play a bit of it
right so you get a sense of how that
works they know what I'm even venture
like if you think that's good you have a
sense does that work for you and if so
why does it work for you what is that
does that seem like an apropos thing to
put mm on to that so you want to take a
venture like yes that works because yeah
right right certainly it is unexpected
and fun to kind of put that together and
it does right do that but other yeah
right so there's definitely old new
right definitely that's there yeah right
right yes yeah so it sort of gives you a
different different take on Eminem right
it rereads him in a different way let me
know I think about ragtime but yeah why
yeah you're yes it was all those things
I mean you were yes well ragtime right I
mean it's a Scott Joplin if you have
this sort of sense again I don't know
how much music history you have right
but I mean this was one of the early
actually white appropriations of a black
form right ragtime was white largely
musicians doing the black music of its
time which is why it was not right it
was it was hep cat music right it was it
was it was hip because it was this white
appropriation of black music so to put
Eminem on it right I think that there's
definitely racial piece that's going on
here in some ways being a modern Scott
Joplin right it's sort of playing with
that I think in ways that again make it
interesting you know sort of
intellectually as well if there's some
some statement there i'm enter a wreath
wreath let me play this for a second
this is well you'll hear it we all know
what it is
I mean I'm old but you're this is all
still you know some idea what this is
right
and it kind of moves in between
okay so does that work and if so like
what does anybody want to try to spin
that in some way as a mashup yeah yeah I
mean there was a certain level of power
playing wave instead like a you know
Hulk vs Superman right the sense of like
railing right to two big powerhouse
emotional people put together other
things with this mashup if it worked for
you
yeah Oh interesting
uh-huh uh-huh i'ma tell I'm a metallic
Apple I was think of them oh right yeah
yeah right I guess yes I get that yeah
right it's all one it's just only two
songs right oh I see them
gotcha gotcha right right right so it
sounded it was willing I've done that
you thought yeah this sounds perfectly
together this does well you lose one
level of meaning right I mean one could
argue that mashup is essentially a kind
of postmodern phenomenon where you don't
you're building things out of pieces and
you don't always have to know the pieces
there's often an additional level of
meaning and I would say it's an
additional level of meaning it was like
I mean recently I figured who did it
that somebody had a big hit with a Joni
Mitchell song I feel like most people
didn't know was a Joni Mitchell song if
you had that kind of backstory you had a
cultural context to her was it yeah I
was big yelling right to who I forget
who did it I mean I feel like now I'm
only because I know Joni Mitchell did
they did they do big gala taxi just
recent yeah I thought it was yeah I mean
she's been very done well maybe right
right
I mean this is a moment that like if you
just heard it you might think yeah great
song and if you had an additional level
does anybody have contacts with like
Metallica or we throw that they think is
yeah yes yeah right right right what
happens right right yeah yeah right she
said get out of bed right right yeah so
I mean right then there is this kind of
way and I think in some ways to know
wreath I mean for me this she goes that
several rights context the gospel
contacts right she's sort of powerful
and God you know godmother is soul kind
of thing right but also to kind of put
that voice on the sort of power chords
you know what I mean like in some ways
for all the kind of angst of the metal
like it's some ways I feel like oh honey
you don't know angst you know what I
mean like okay there's a sort of way in
which you know I mean I I am certain you
know I'm married to drummer and I have
certainly loved my share of like whining
white boys but there is definitely a
little bit of a moment of like like
seriously I'm not sure you know to take
the kind of anger you know what I mean
like the anger of the metal and I
actually kind of put that voice on top
of it I think is really interesting
right it really least changes where the
the direction of that that kind of power
um yes okay and so text um obviously you
know start to do too much text in in a
PowerPoint text is the first mass media
I think could forget text at you know as
a mass media right remember the
Gutenberg parentheses right the sense
that text kind of formalizes things and
starts is a one-way transmission you
know from a particular point of view um
there are really two kinds of sort of
texture
remix I mean there is pastiche and
parody
I have fanfiction these amateur textual
remix and I think fanfiction is is one
of them but parity and pastiche inand
the kind of work that people do just
really for love right people are often
kind of doing literary parodies and in
various kinds of ways I have a note in
here about whenever I hear amateur I
would love you to hear the lake amare
and amateur write amateur is for love I
think that you know it's a it's a side
effect of mass culture that we think of
amateur meaning bad or awful or inferior
right I think that's kind of almost
offensive I think the idea of amateur is
often the amateur is the person who does
it for the love of it and many amateurs
are also a really good it's just that
they're they're less interested in a
commercial context it to be an amateur
does not mean that you're bad at what
you do and in fact often is a sense that
professionals in in contrast are kind of
hacks compared to the amateur right
they're the people who do some things
because they love it and then there's a
sense in which like you're only doing it
for money I I feel like people feel that
way about sort of if you consider say
the poet versus like the television
writer right and you think like who is a
figure of greater authenticity to you I
think there's a sense of which people
feel like the poet who's probably doing
it for almost no money right is doing it
for love of the genre of poetry which is
not that profitable versus you know the
TV writer who's always framed you know
as a hack regardless of whether or not
they are a hack but I kind of want to
spin it that way for you so there's
definitely the internet is full of
amateur textual remix um I want to note
and we'll we can talk about these
differently these are all different
legal cases but there's really a large
body of professional textual remix there
are books like Wide Sargasso Sea right
which is a rewriting of Jane Eyre which
they can do because it's what's a
prequel well it's yes but it takes us
through the through the action right but
they can do it because it's out of
copyright right so that in some ways the
legitimacy of this is not actually about
the art form right what makes something
fan fiction versus what makes something
as in the case of March which retails
Little Women right from the perspective
of the dad also out of copyright I think
when the Booker Prize right you can win
major literary prizes if you're dealing
with something that's out of copyright
and yet does this way in which trait
it's probably fanfiction if it's
something in copyright and you don't
technically have the legal rights to do
it though other cases the wind done gone
is that a case that you guys have
studied or yes the wind done gone is we
know we read have gone with the wind and
was defended in court her her even
though Gone with the Wind is not out of
copyright the court ruled that she was
allowed to do that
Louis diary which is a retelling of
Lolita from from lolita's point of view
was done by an Italian often in Pia
Parra that's an interesting case because
he didn't go to court they settled they
decided to split the proceeds
fifty-fifty but she was allowed to
publish the book and they just split the
profits evenly I'm kind of always
curious about what would have happened
if they'd gone to court if they would
have seen it as a fair use or if they
would have seen it as a derivative work
we recently and there's still some
fighting about this book called 60 years
on which is a sequel to The Catcher in
the Rye which you may be following or
studying um the court ruled against them
and I think though the US courts did
it's published in Europe and South
America and other places it is not
allowed to be published in the United
States and I think the US Court felt
that it was writing to rather too much
on the code heels of capture and the
ride that it was not sort of
sufficiently transformative but was sort
of merely a sequel I disagree with that
ruling but I I sort of understand you
know where they were coming from right
books like Ahab his wife for taking Moby
Dick from a different place we've had a
hundred years of Sherlock Holmes write
stories I mean the number of different
writers who have taken on that character
and done their own spin on it right and
so legally each of these is sort of
different but to recognize that this is
not that substantially different from a
mature textual remix in the in the form
of fan fiction it on our archive the
archive of our own our supplies like
fanfiction.net etc I have yuletide up
there Yuletide is a something I wanna
give a little shout out to you tide is a
little fanfiction exchange that's done
at around the holidays every year where
about 2,000 people sort of play well you
request a story
often in 4a for something that that
people don't generally write about I
mean a sort of a fanfiction about a book
that you loved or a obscure film you saw
once or and somebody will and you can
tell people like I really wish that
there were a story where such-and-such
happens and somebody will like hand make
you a piece of literature it's like a
secret santa for fiction will make you a
story to your specifications and this so
it's a Secret Santa story exchange and
to me again that's the absolute
antithesis of mass culture where it's
like you want a story in which the color
read fiction it figures in which
such-and-such happens and what's your
favorite thing and your favorite
character and the ending turned out
differently and somebody will write that
story for you with your name on it right
that is text not as math culture it's
closer to to telling your kid a bedtime
story
right the sense of what you're gonna
kind of personalize a story as opposed
to having it be something produced at a
distance by strangers in identical form
right this is stories in personalized
form making a story like knitting a
sweater I think that's actually
interesting and meaningful um
other kinds right of textual parody I
just picked something really short right
but the they're often moments where the
internet will interrupt into translating
literature until while cat which i think
is just something worth doing do people
know what lolcat is I'm having write the
way cats would talk if they could talk
cat syntax
um right so this is William Carlos
Williams is so much depends upon a red
wheelbarrow glazed with rain water
beside the right with the white chickens
right and the translation of the wall
cat you know weird wheelbarrow is
serious business
I Can Has chicken right um the chicken
becomes a inedible right and and and
people have done this is a you know a
quickie people have done really
wonderful elaborate literary parody to
that I could think of teaching them
there's a Harry Potter wasteland a whole
version of TS Eliot's the wasteland sort
of done in the Harry Potter universe
which is really quite good somebody has
done the love song of Admiral Piett you
might say who is Admiral Piett and he is
one of the sort of secondary Star Wars
villains who Darth Vader strangles and
somebody has done I mean a whole TS
Eliot the love song of him and people
have been fairly elaborate remixed
poetry and other kinds of pests
video this is what you were sort of
reading about this is the work I've been
doing lately there's a staggering
variety of remix video that people are
using as forms of speech and you know
III interrupt here to say you know as an
educator people are constituting about
like filmic literacy or the idea of
Internet literacy or digital literacy
and yet the culture is so resistant to
the idea of what that literacy means
which is that you you get to write as
well as read with film or with with
image right um that's what it would mean
to be literate that it's a readwrite
culture right in the way that we expect
you to read books and then also be able
to write essays digital literacy and
media literacy means the ability to
write with image and so we talk this
talk of media literacy and yet you know
you get the sense in the legal climate
they're not quite comfortable with
giving to image the full array of rights
that you have with text you expected
you're gonna be able to quote you expect
that you're gonna be able to to do
things with text build your ideas on
other people's ideas write parodies of
books etc etc well people do not assume
that you're gonna be able to do this
with video right and so you make it
takedown notices or cease and desist
letters right that the status of this is
a lot dodgy er in reality though I think
at some point they're gonna have to
realize that image and video needs to
have all the rights that you have with
text but we're getting there
anyway a staggering variety of remix
videos political remix video PRV anime
music video lip dub sprite machinima
which is cinema made inside a video game
engines right people seen red vs. blue
for instance or there's a ton of like
little reggae little Mario Mario
Brothers stuff I mean a little sort of
little big world stuff that the people
are making inside literally filming
their movies inside the video game
engines literal videos right I had a
hard time actor I was looking recently
they're taking down the literal videos
again that's another case where I think
it's kind of clear-cut fair use and yet
you know every so often I'm looking for
a little video and it says this you know
I get the YouTube squiggly lines right
of this is video has been removed for a
Content infringement fan films right and
venting which is what I work on now if
you want to sort of see all of these
different modes
send it to us cease 24/7 DIY video shows
their shows are all online and they do a
really wonderful exhibition of curated
forms a remix video there that you with
them they do excerpts and they link to
the full videos on the web and that's a
tremendous resource for anybody who
wants to research the kind of broader
DIY video so as they're saying the legal
status of all these various forms you
know is unclear and even when they are
legal you know legal doesn't mean that
you don't get taken down YouTube mainly
runs by algorithms most people don't
know their rights did anybody see did
you do YouTube's pirate school yet you
have fun with that right I mean but like
where the user is already framed as like
a squirrel with a pirate hat on I mean I
think once you framed your user is
wearing a pirate hat you're not really
conceptualizing them as an artist or a
fair user you've already sort of
prejudge the case I think if the user
you're addressing is a squirrel but
secondly a squirrel dressed as a pirate
right it does set it suggested you're
already guilty before you even started
but there's not a whole lot of emphasis
on YouTube about how to fight your
takedown so if your video is caught in
the web or somehow triggers some
algorithm and and again a person's not
looking at it just some computer is
looking at it they'll take you down even
if it's your rights and one of things
that you know we do with the
organisation for transformative works is
try to be a resource for people
sometimes hold their hand or give them
language to use to help them go through
the dispute process and say my video is
not a pirated thing my video is a fair
use remix my video and the
transformative work my video is free
speech so people don't often know to do
that another thing that the OTW did my
group is we went to the Library of
Congress two years ago to fight for an
exemption for non-commercial remixers of
all kinds to be able to rip DVDs and we
did actually succeed in getting that
exemption I went down and testified and
so it is now legal for you to rip a DVD
to make a fair use video and that's
important for a number of reasons but
one of the reasons that it's important
is that you couldn't even begin to argue
for the fairness of this stuff in court
because often you had broken a law in
the making
and those the thing you had made was
fair but the technique you use to make
it if you ripped the DVD was de facto
illegal so you it sort of it was
essentially kind of you know having to
break into a house to make a piece of
art that was then legitimate right so by
removing that you couldn't even get to
that point because nobody wanted to say
yeah by the way I did this illegal thing
to have my free speech um so now that's
removed it is now you know legal to do
this and so I mean again I hope there
will never be a case I hope the the
content companies will have some sense
and figure out ways for people to have
their speech without thus ending up in
court but it will make it a lot easier
to argue for the legitimacy of this now
that we don't have to be worried you
know about the means though we're going
back you have to go every three years
which is kind of a pain and it's ownerís
for the average person right to say I'm
gonna go to Congress and fight for my
exemption every three years
but of course blu-ray is the next kind
of frontier right that one of the things
we want to do is try to get these rights
extended to blu-ray which are again the
discs that people have on hand you know
lesson can say it's readwrite culture
but right now it's read-only culture
you're not necessarily allowed to make
stuff out of it um oh yes I'm gonna show
a vid I want to show a music video right
I know you I think you were assigned my
piece and there are some videos older
videos largely embedded in there I
wanted to show one called the price but
before I do you kind of need to know
about man pain because it's a vid about
man pain and so I wanted to give you
this definition of man pain which will
help you make sense of the video man
pain is a term fans used to describe a
set of narrative devices when a main
characters of a story always male
generally white is written with a
particular kind of psychologically
painful history that causes him to
behave in certain ways
he has man pain batman is probably the
absolute may plus ultra of man pain
batman is a man with a lot of pain um it
is excessive right his tragedies are
extreme like both my parents were dead
my wife was hung from a tree my baby was
swung around on a rope right my sister
has been kidnapped my wife has been
raped by gangs of hordes raping you know
this story right like there's a sense of
the kind of the guy is completely over
you know my mother was kidnapped and set
on fire that's supernatural I mean I'm
not even kick you're gonna see all these
stories or if there's a sense of the
real excessive tragedy not literal
like my mom my sister died of leukemia
or something like this but was you know
kidnapped by hoards of aliens and then
set on fire in public right like
literally huge excessive tragedy
consequently his pain is worse than
anyone elses right Batman feels more
than URI it's self-centered right
there's a sense of which the traumatic
events are viewed through the lens of
how they impact a bearer of man pain
right who's kind of a figure of
isolation so Batman off has to go on
rubes and stare moodily out at the city
for which he has this huge
responsibility and yet so much pain
alright
you can picture Batman doing this right
um the painful history as I say it's
frequently created by explaining the
death suffering or loss of a woman or
children or both these women are
children are not important in the
narrative except that they have caused
the man pain right you're recognizing
this right like hi there's a girl friend
and you see her for five minutes and
then she's dead um the word that fans
use is fringed and it comes from the
Green Lantern cuz there was this Green
Lantern series where there may be not
anybody Green Lantern came home and
found his girlfriend dead in the fridge
um everything went okay right I mean
that was her sole function and then he
could have man pain see and then he can
go and have a whole story right because
he's traumatized now and he must revenge
the girlfriend and it sets him off on
his arc and we sort of pan away from her
and he said say she's not that and she's
just in the fridge there oh just any
movie I mean just but I mean if you're
gladiator right I mean your gladiator
and your wife was hung from the roof
your lethal weapon and your wife died
before it began you're the fugitive and
then you know the man with one arm is
killed you're maybe just think goes on
and on like I mean just pick it just
it's just your BIC witness right I've
been hearing people yelling out right
brave I mean just when I'm right
somebody's gone and killed your whole
family we know your parents have been
shot your mother is on fine I'm like now
your planet your you even even did it
they gave uh I didn't even think Spock
could have man pain but now Spock's
whole planet blew up last movie it
didn't before our Vulcan was there and
he had a mom and dad he was like a
normal dude but not anymore now Spock
even Spock
the most automatic emotional man in the
world has man pain because they blew up
his whole planet and his mom right right
so Erin this says but again what what
does it do right
it shows often a very powerful male
character is kind of vulnerable and
sympathetic
um and then kind of excuse is like once
you have man pain you're sort of allowed
to kind of become a psychotic weirdo
do you see I'm saying because you have
so much pain you can kill everybody then
you see I'm saying you can you can go
you can be tortured you can be a
complete whack job right because there's
a sense it was well here's man pain so
he had to kill everyone he has to
torture people right he has to do what
he has to do because they put his baby
you get on a stick that's what they did
and now he's twisted right I mean it's a
joke but it's not anything it's not a
joke it is a joke the the vid is I think
both funny and is about this so I need
to I I if you were my class we would
watch the video and then we would come
back and then we would talk about it and
we talk about man pain and then we go
back but since I don't have that much
time and we want to have a conversation
I'm front loading it with man pain so
that you can get that context can I take
the light down a little bit just to see
because if it could be a little dark
because these are brooding men they're
often in the dark can I do okay okay wow
that's an easy one right just to fully
appreciate the the man pain whoops
okay so I've topped this piece and we
could spend quite a long time talking
about it we should talk about it at
least a little bit it's actually kind of
complicated I there's quite a lot going
on here right the more did you recognize
something you can sort of front-loaded
the meaning for you enough that I think
it's good that you're laughing it's very
black right this is well it's a very
black comedy here that's sort of going
on right does anybody want to kind of
comment on this do you see this sparkly
tears of man pain poor babies it's
horrible right how does this been work
did it work for you or how do you see
this as working yeah right almost
identical tragedy right right that's
right and what I think that Vitter's do
and again this is a fair use issue is
show patterns and tropes right so I mean
I don't really see so many people in
life like stumbling around carrying the
dead bodies of their relatives as they
do in almost all TV write another it's
not enough that somebody stabbed you
have to kind of pick them up and walk
around with them for a while right um
that seems to me to happen very rarely
in real life but an awful lot right on
television and in movies as a kind of
sign and yet you know the thing that you
want to say there is poor him I think I
hope when you look at the whole video
you sort of take like poor them right
like it's in a moment of like pay no
attention the actual women are being
like thrown off of buildings in the
background you know what I mean so that
like Mulder can feel bad about himself
yeah right yeah right right
to cry right right
right we'll Orly and I think the you
know what a good Vitter and she is a
very good Vitter this is a bitter cold
things with wings right man by men she
has herself there's a thing goodbye
things with wings a good Vitter will
turn the lyrics into a kind of poetry by
you know but by using a phrase like the
price right and giving you images this
song is telling you how to understand
what you see right and I think when the
first times we see the price we see the
mom on supernatural on fire on the
ceiling right and at some level we get
the sense that like women's pain is the
price but to pray the song also tells us
right the price is getting higher and so
by the end you have like whole planets
whole world it's not even enough for you
know one woman to die like everybody
must die there's a moment where there's
stumbling through like fields of corpses
right so there's something about I mean
I think we love mean the other thing
about Vitter's as a particular kind of
remix artist is we love all of this
right like we love these guys like these
are our guys right and yet you love
these guys and you are critical at the
same time I mean there's only these are
shows that you love and yet there's only
so many dead women right that at some
moment you can take I mean I definitely
I've had moments where I'm like please
like do not introduce this woman just to
kill her to give up give us another
story I feeling bad from it like it
means you often see women introduced and
you think like how many episodes right
how many episodes before they throw are
for building if you haven't had that
thought you should have it now like this
wreck it when you see enough like I am
older than you and like when you're like
oh look he's got a girl oh no you have
that moment of oh - ran run away don't
date Batman you know what I mean like
you don't want to date that go date some
date the nice accountant you know what I
mean like you do not want to date Batman
because it's really only so long before
somebody's gonna throw you off a
building and again and altar with the
total some bees lack of sympathy for you
I mean that there's a way in which they
the bells the there's often insufficient
empathy should have built up for the
women like the empathy is really all
directed towards what the men are
feeling um and I think we as women fans
are also really sympathetic you know to
what the men are feeling yeah
yeah and they're like you've never
noticed in an individual a fandoms that
you're right okay especially right right
right I think I mean France not yet too
into like I think in Doctor Who fandom I
think by the end a lot of people were
fed up with ten feeling that like that
feeling that he was a little bit that it
was a little too much about him and a
little not enough about the companions
but what I'm thinking that I don't know
that these are always majority points of
view I mean I think kind of good for you
I mean often it is the case where these
things are engineered to make the men
more interesting or to further their
stories or that just they're allowed to
kind of and some of you are sort of
saying get over it and move on with your
life you know Lee Adama you know what I
mean like I said get on with it you know
but Yoshi don't do the pile of rocks
like if you know the scene from
Battlestar Galactica right I mean she
gets to die and then he gets to feel
something but but I mean how excessive
is the bar for two and what did it say
about masculinity I mean I think you
could you know men do cry right I mean
this is also suggesting what you were
saying about gender you're saying men
don't cry well teeny men maybe don't cry
but you know men cry you know I'm saying
I don't I don't I mean I thought you
know I'm I'm not accusing anybody of
anything but I'm saying I think you know
possibly if your girlfriend broke her
leg you would be really sad about that
you would probably be scared you would
probably leap into a taxi and run to the
hospital and be sufficiently whatever
without actually having her say you know
ripped to pieces by the Joker and and
then thrown out of a building you seen
anything like this I said of mom and I'm
like but he would never cry it really
has to be you know this excessive level
of things yeah
right right right so I guess how he has
boy Peyton Harry Potter but there there
is a way I mean summers I would love I
would love to see it I'm sure some fan
has written you know the Harry Potter
saga like from lilies you know
point-of-view but Lily isn't many ways a
kind of engine of the thing and her
story is kind of subsumed and we even
find more about James than we do really
ultimately about her right but her death
is really important for the way which it
drives her her love is the sky right and
there's a kind of way in which she's the
engine but not there's a the suggestion
is that these women's stories would not
themselves be interesting and it doesn't
seem to matter if they're you know
fighting if their time Timelord
companions or i mean doesn't matter how
interesting they are the story just
doesn't kind of go with them it's sort
of it really kind of uses them in a way
to kind of continue to go on with the
men and i think that this is actually by
the way not reflective of the sexism of
the audience i think in fact this is
reflective of the sexism of the content
producers i find actual men an actual
men are less psychotic then TV men i
often wonder like what men think you
know they sort of depiction i mean men
are always sort of grabbing each other
and pushing themselves up against walls
right I mean they always having a very
physical confrontation slamming each
other against cars on TV I see very few
men actually you know so you took my
coke you know I'm going to push her
against the wall and you know I mean but
they they sort of do that on TV all the
time they're right physical with each
other they're all carrying guns they
think you know this level of masculinity
I don't actually see in the men that I
meet in the world who all seem
unpleasant chaps that you might be happy
to know you know I've dinner with so so
I just sort of wonder what's going on in
Hollywood that there's this that this
the sense of this is what masculinity
has to look like in representation um
the last thing I wanted to talk about in
terms of remix is code which I suppose
is the one you all know most about but
normally in my audiences it's the one
they haven't thought about but code is a
form of writing right people are now
talking about code and the writing of
code is a creative artistic act and one
of the things that I wanted to to say
about code is that the internet is
becoming this place this is a lot of as
a TLD alright um he'll there I'll tell
you what I want you to know from this
slide
as new software and social media tools
are developing fewer people are writing
their own web pages um maybe in this
room or their own programs um I kind of
come from the sort of older web where
before YouTube before you know WordPress
and LiveJournal and before like
everything was kind of a program where
you could just put your content up in
many ways that's great for participation
right somebody with no technical skills
can create a wordpress blog in five
minutes and start posting you can create
you know a youtube account and start
hosting your own video but in the sort
of older web there's a little bit more
of a roll your own code aesthetic and I
am a little bit concerned that things
are going kind of and I love Apple many
of us love Apple but it's kind of going
the Apple way where you can't hack the
tools anymore that in trying to make
them idiot-proof they're making them
hacker-proof are you following what I'm
saying and there's a way in which I'm
actually kind of suggesting right that
that we need to kind of write fanfic of
code I think the open-source movement is
really important but that code should
stay amateur to some degree or that we
should not lose the ability to think of
ourselves as makers of code the way we
seem to be losing our ability to think
of ourselves as players of poker or
writers of stories or makers of movies
do you see what I'm saying
and is that the act the activity there
the participation that again I'm
thinking a career science department so
you may you may feel this sort of less
but I think the average person is is not
even being encouraged they can just
choose a skin they don't even have to
learn as they did you know how to put
the colors on that do some simple CSS or
do some simple HTML or do do that and I
think there's a danger of the
professionalization and this is what I
say here that I think we're seeing the
mass culture ization of the internet
like I don't want the internet to be a
thing made by specialists that you just
use I hate this language of users do you
see them saying as opposed to makers
where we all made the internet they used
in that internet right the sort of sense
in which we were all kind of hacking it
and making it together and that the you
the internet was a series of sites that
people had made some better you know
when Jia settees fell you're all too
young really for jia jia settees was
like a tidal wave of sort of bad web
design but it was so beautiful about
that too like everybody had made their
ugly pages with the rotating gifs
the yellow font on a black background
under construction this is kind of like
amateur right it was not sleek and sexy
it didn't have all the kind of
prettiness of a wordpress blog that you
can get out of the box but there was
something kind of great and amateur and
gritty about it and I'm a little bit
worried that that the code is going to
go back to omens Wright's gonna be made
by specialists at a distance and like
the average took me don't worry your
pretty little heads about the code so I
think it's really important to invest in
in people doing that and again the OTW
my group is actually the largest
all-female open-source project but
building a fan fiction archive and we're
teaching women to code in Ruby and at
whatever level they're interested in
kind of engaging but we sort of think
it's important to kind of not lose fans
you know come out of you know science
I mean fans tend to come out of science
fiction departments which are tend to be
closely aligned with science and
engineering and computer science
departments we have a high proportion of
sis admin's and and kind of hack early
types and we kind of don't want to lose
that skill set and I think the more
important than women don't lose that
skill set that they had right so this
idea that individuals use the web or now
users or subscribers or customers rather
than creators or members or architects
you know is is bad right so we need to
remix the code we need to love the code
and so again our project does that it's
a sort of my conclusion here the archive
of our own if you feel like you want to
come and hang out in our chat rooms and
work on a fan fiction archive come join
us
there's a blog system called dream with
which forked off some of the live
journal people forked off the code from
live journal literally to sort of create
a kind of more open source version of it
like it's got a heavy fan and creative
base but invites the users to kind of
hack and work on the code in a
particular way that again I think is
important sites like anime music videos
or have always been kind of they own
their own location right their donor
supported and they they they host anime
music videos on their own site and they
work it together and I think that these
kinds of local things that are opposed
to the kind of conglomerates of the
YouTube or blogs etc are important right
again I suspect I'm preaching is
converted here um
so that is it for the moment and we'll
take questions and we can talk about you
know whatever pieces of this we're most
interesting to you so thank you you okay
okay great what does anybody want to
talk about yeah correct
right but it is a smart or interesting I
mean you know what it reminds me of it's
like you know I'm not sure what to do
about that except that it's kind of the
it's the price I say that um you know
they did this thing at the democracy
wall would you remember this I mean they
they went in and you know in Washington
and they put up this like democracy wall
where people could write things on the
democracy wall and it will shock you to
know I mean people were like Jefferson
sucks dick on the democra you know and
like they had to go and erase that right
but I mean and this is the democracy
wall right I mean on some level that's
kind of what the democracy wall looks
like you know it really depends
obviously if you're dealing with things
that are that are dangerous
I mean for instance I think the privacy
issues on the web are very complicated I
actually come down on the other side of
the anonymity there's a so there's an
argument right now that says that we
ought to respond to the fact that people
make often discuss things say YouTube
comments or trolling kinds of comments
by requiring everybody to operate on the
web under their legal name I am NOT of
that party I mean I think pseudonyms are
important I think the ability to have
multiple pseudonyms is important and I
say that not from a sense of
irresponsibility but that in some ways
it's a privilege to be able to operate
under one name most people for various
reasons can't in practice which is to
say that you might not want to have your
political you know do you want your
employer knowing your political
affiliations do you want you know you
you want the right to be able to join a
mailing list for people of your sexual
orientation without necessarily having
it be Google Bowl by everybody in the
whole world right and so I think the
privacy concerns I think often when
people are calling for like everybody to
just work under one name they're you
know they're not thinking about women
who are being stalked by exes right this
is a kind of classic case of this where
they say well use your own name and put
your location and the answer is like no
I don't I write I don't want to be
located in that way I have reasons for
my privacy so I think that in an odd way
to culture of anonymity I might like
hurt your feelings but as long as
there's no actual danger to you I think
it's sadly the price that gets paid and
I think there are ways that you can set
up communities I mean YouTube I don't
generally
hosting YouTube because it's kind of too
big and it's not my audience I think in
some ways the solution is more
individualized kind of community police
areas like the community at YouTube is
kind of too big for people to kind of
police like just I don't like you know I
mean in that sense of police not like
copyright police but they're a smaller
they're going to be like smaller kind of
hosting sites where you're posting your
video to people who are like-minded and
you will often find that the community
will essentially kind of shun people who
are rude or vicious and I think that
kind of social pressure is better than
trying to legislate that that would be
my answer to that other things that
people want to talk about yeah right
they borrowed a lot from amateur bidding
and trailers and in professional stuff
yeah right I'm actually working on that
now I mean this - they're almost two
issues there one of it is that you and
you're dealing in the professional
marketplace there is kind of a the
addition of profit right the the fact of
not being amateur not done like for love
or as a form of speech but in somebody's
done as part of a money-making
Enterprise tends to I want to be clear
about this and I'm sure commerciality
does not mean you you there are fair
uses that can also be commercial uses so
I'm not saying that because it's
commercial I mean that's not fair use
you can totally have so I could imagine
the case where it's commercial and it's
also fair use a good example of that for
instance is documentary filmmakers who
are often making of you know their
documentary
that's what they're gonna do but that
their use of the clip and their
documentary is fair use even though it's
a taken clip right since unchanged
dropped in there often that is regarded
as a fair use of that material despite
it being a kind of commercial project
but in the case of like using it for a
trailer or a theme song or something
like that it kind of fits into it there
is a market for that right and so in
some ways it's about you know not trying
to get away with not being in the market
I'd like to get something free that
we're normally there is a you there is a
well-established procedure to license a
song for use in this way which what's me
is worse is I mean sometimes when they
come to the the DVDs right where they
put out they put out the DVDs of a show
that broadcast and they can't get the
rights and then they have to read that's
often terrible right I mean that to me
seems really awful where they can't use
the music they originally used that was
really meaningful at that moment right
but that at least is the kind of well
understood sort of market in the case of
fan visits if not it usually is
something that somebody feels kind of
compelled to say you know a response
that they kind of feel compelled to make
at that moment so that it really is more
like a speech than a commercial product
if that's if that makes sense that
they're trying to say something and this
is what they're using it to say I've
been working on the you know trying to
explain how music functions and vetting
and one of the arguments that I've been
making is that and this is a complicated
argument I'll try to summarize very
quickly but that that the emitters are
transforming in an event like that
a kind of narrative drama into a kind of
poetic drama that actually song which is
more more closely related to poetry
which is more related to forms like the
soliloquy or the Aria in opera right the
moment where somebody stops and then
sing right if you see Monty Python IFFA
I'm having a Monty Python moment right
where that poor prince and the tower
keeps wanting to sing right the
expression of feeling or as Wordsworth
to say the spontaneous overflow of
powerful emotion is something more about
song and poetry than it is about like
the TV dramas that most of these is a
mostly action-adventure plot narrative
driven and the music is affecting a kind
of transformation of what the thing is
that you're creating you're giving voice
- an emotion in a genre that doesn't
normally allow for it and that that's
kind of transformative in a in a
different way than a soundtrack is you
see I'm saying we're probably the Big
Bang Theory is more like a soundtrack to
images which is a slightly different
thing these are fine distinctions I
think they're kind of important is that
remotely persuasive other things people
want to talk about yeah
fair dealing yeah yeah I think it's a
bad idea
and I'll tell you why a lot of times the
people who do the moral rights arguments
they often talk as if the works were
their children there's a kind of classic
actually rhetorical mover it's like it's
my this is my baby
you know you're messing with my child
and I always feel that somebody who says
that actually doesn't understand much
about parenting either which is to say
your children who you do not own will
associate with people whom you do not
like and go places where you think they
shouldn't and hang out with just
reputable types on the internet you know
I feel like yes in fact I feel like yes
maybe they are your children in which
case you actually do not have the right
I mean makes me a little afraid for
their actual children I mean thank you
see I'm saying is let's keep you at home
you may only speak with whom I associate
oh and you may only where would I put
you in and the answer is no children
once born will run around and turn up in
other people's videos and sleep over
people's houses right and do things that
you don't like um and I feel like the
moral rights people have to kind of get
that on board
I do understand I mean you know you
people always kind of cope with the
extreme you know cases of the you know
the abstinence movement who wants to use
like a virgin right Madonna's like and
you sort of say like where Madonna
really hates that message you know but I
mean one things about free speech is you
don't get to I think I thought by the
way I thought it was wrong yeah I was
gonna say but also the McCain like that
that a lot of Democratic artists tried
to stop Republicans from from using
their songs not not just as like again
if the soundtrack then it's like you get
to you could go and license it that's a
market but there were often places where
there were creative remixes being done
in a certain way
a-and then the artists were like no you
can't do that and I thought that was
really hypocritical and instead even
even though they were you know sort of
my candidates I was like no that's not
you shouldn't you shouldn't squelch that
speech the answer is more speech so I'm
not crazy about the moral rights
argument I just think it doesn't reflect
how creativity actually you know works
you know and then you want is you want
other people I mean I teach Shakespeare
also and you know Shakespeare one of the
reasons we still care about Shakespeare
400 years later is a lot of people have
gone in and messed with it
you see I'm saying in other words nobody
really does want it huh oh yes sure
absolutely but even not even not even
that extreme and example of that kind of
a remix but in other words you know
interestingly we're doing the plays that
have the issues that speak to us that we
are kind of drawing parallels that
shakes were never intended I mean if
you're talking about Merchant of Venice
and being Jewish you're talking about a
fellow and race or you'reyou're doing
Ian McKellen's Richard the third where
you're making you're making a fascist
environment for Richard right directors
do that on stage all the time I think
they mess with it and they make it
completely not at all what Shakespeare
wanted because they're making it
relevant and interesting to the audience
and consequently we're still caring
about these plays 400 years after the
fact so work lasts when it's it's messed
with and so that's it's actually the
best thing you can do I mean the other
thing I often tell like artists it's
like you should be so like you should be
so lucky all of you who want to be like
artists you should be so lucky that
somebody wants to to cover your song
right to remix your song to sing your
song to to remix your movie to parity or
it's only the top I mean that's how you
know you've arrived right is that
somebody's engaged with your story to
the degree to which they either want
they want to argue about it or they want
to talk back to it or something like
this and it's absolute mark of success
and I do not understand songwriters I
mean who are literally like do not
saying you know do not sing my song
right I mean if you did a song that was
great everybody's gonna sing it and
they're gonna sit someone some of them
might sing it badly right and that's
like suck it up I mean that's that's the
way that that is other things people
want to want to talk about
you're welcome thanks very much